if you remember our discussion from a
long time ago we said that much of this
class consists of variations of a few
basic skills and ideas one of which is
the Bayes rule the foundation of
inference so let us look here at the
Bayes rule again and it's different
incarnations in a discrete setting we
have a random variable with a known PMF
but whose values are not observed
instead we observe the value of another
random variable call it Y which has some
relation with X and we will use the
value of Y to make some inferences about
X the relation between the two random
variables is captured by specifying the
conditional PMF of Y given any value of
x think of X as an unknown state of the
world and of Y as a noisy observation of
X the conditional PMF tells us the
distribution of Y under each possible
state of the world once we observe the
value of y we obtain some information
about X and we use this information to
make inferences about the likely values
of X mathematically instead of relying
on the prior for X we form some revised
beliefs that is we form the conditional
PDF of X given the particular
observation that we have seen all this
becomes possible because of the Bayes
rule we have seen the Bayes rule for
events but it is easy to translate into
PMF notation we take the multiplication
rule and we use it twice in different
orders to get two different forms or two
different expressions for the joint PMF
we then take one of the terms involved
here and send it to the other side we
obtain this expression which is the
Bayes rule what we have here we want to
calculate the conditional distribution
of X which we typically call the
posterior
and to do this we rely on the prior of X
as well as on the model that we have for
the observations the denominator
requires us to compute the marginal of Y
but this is something that is easily
done because we have the joint available
the numerator this expression here is
just the joint pmf and using the joint
pmf you can always find the marginal PMF
essentially we're using here the total
probability theorem and we're using the
pieces of information that were given to
us the prior and the model of the
observations when we are dealing with
continuous random variables the story is
identical we still have two versions of
the multiplication rule by sending one
term this term to the other side of the
equation we get the Bayes rule and then
we use the total probability theorem to
calculate the denominator term so as far
as mathematics go the story is pretty
simple and is exactly the same in the
discrete and the continuous case this
story will be our stepping stone for
dealing with more complex models and
also when we go into more detail on the
subject of inference later in this
course